[Music]
this year gave us a bevy of amazing new
3ds games reinforcing yet again by
Nintendo's popular handheld is the most
consistent well-rounded portable console
on the market with lineup that includes
new and exciting games from iconic
series there were a wide variety of
experiences to latch onto from games
with complex mechanics that tested our
strategic and tactical metal -
adventures that pull us into fantastical
world's the 3ds was on a roll in 2016
with the year about to come to a close
we've narrowed down the five best 3ds
games that you need to add to your
collection in no particular order here's
our best of 3ds from 2016 in an
unorthodox yet ambitious move for a new
Fire Emblem game
Fire Emblem fates was divided into three
different adventures birthright conquest
and revelation unless you're one of the
lucky few who managed to pick up the
limited edition that combined all three
games on one cartridge you had to
purchase three separate games to
experience faces entire story each
throws you into a conflict between two
warring families where you must choose
whom to pledge your allegiance to but
which side do you choose the version you
play dictates that choice regardless of
the path you take fates has some of the
best most challenging tactical combat
the series has to offer with clever and
intricate maps that weave a multitude of
ever-evolving and meaningful struggles
in the relationships you build with your
allies along the way create even more
impactful conflicts as you wage war and
walk the righteous path fates may veer
away from the series tradition in its
format but it provides across its three
versions the signature epic narrative
and strategic turn-based battles that
fans have come to love it's by far one
of the most diverse distinct and
fulfilling games on 3ds this year at
first glance Shin Megami Tensei for
apocalypse might seem like a rudimentary
expansion to 2013's well-received Shin
Megami Tensei 4 but it's so much more
core features like combat demon hunting
and questing are refined or bolstered by
new ideas demons now have innate buffs
or D buffs to certain skill types which
gives the fusion process a new level of
depth as you reconsider what skills it
needs the pacing of apocalypses story
also much tighter quickly throwing you
into the conflict terrorizing Tokyo and
at the center is its protagonist Nana
she a demon hunter brought back to life
who must decide whether to follow the
commands of the benefactor that revived
him or to rebel enhancements like these
result in an experience that manages to
outshine the original games already
stellar foundation Shin Megami Tensei
for apocalypse is not only one of the
best RPGs on 3ds this year it's one of
the best the handheld has to offer
Pokemon Sun and Moon launched in
November to the delight of series fans
everywhere the latest entry is sure to
please the most devoted players by
trading familiar ground but it also
introduces new features that make the
traditional Pokemon experience more
accessible to new players the structure
of the adventure has been revamped
Travel simplified and combat made more
intuitive through small but meaningful
interface upgrades but the refinements
don't stop there
Sun and moons visuals are some of the
most memorable in the entire series the
beautiful Hawaiian inspired a lowland
region is a delight to explore and in
keeping with tradition the new Pokemon
roster is vibrant charming and
expressive Sun and Moon is a reminder
why Pokemon has consistently remained
one of the most powerful and iconic
franchises in gaming kirby planet
robobot embodies the same fundamental
tron that has made past kirby games so
endearing it's not a drastic reinvention
of the formula by any means but it
doesn't need to be what's contained in
planet robobot is the classic kirby
experience you run around absorbing
enemy abilities and use them for your
own game but the wonderful addition this
time around is the use of powerful robot
suits which gives the heroic pink puffs
added strength and access to a distinct
set of moves and abilities Robo BOTS
level design is also some of the best of
the series yet encouraging exploration
and replayability and myriad extra modes
add more variety to an otherwise
enjoyable platformer you can play
through the entire game as Meta Knight
there's Kirby 3d Rumble a mini game
where you dispatch enemies using as few
moves as possible and there's even team
Kirby clash a mode that allows you to
team up with AI or nearby friends to
tackle bosses and a medieval fantasy
themed setting the sheer diversity of
content offered here makes planet
robobot one of the best Kirby games in
recent
memory rhythm heaven megamix marks the
first time the cult favorite rhythm
games series has appeared on 3ds
bringing with it the oftentimes absurd
scenarios it's known for like past games
megamix presents simple minigames that
rely on one or two buttons that you have
to press in time with quirky original
music it's bright and charming art style
inspire nothing but joy as you
rhythmically pick the beard hairs off of
an onion or catch pineapples falling
down a flight of stairs megamix is
catchy music and ridiculous situations
make it consistently endearing it gives
fans more of what they've always loved
and is sure to surprise newcomers with
its unconventional sense of humor if you
haven't played a Rhythm Heaven game
before you owe it to yourself to
experience the absurd yet uplifting ride
that is Rhythm Heaven megamix
[Music]